so let's think a little bit about waves
and the classical notion of what a wave
is it's a disturbance traveling through
a medium
disturbance
traveling
through through
a medium so what do we mean by a
disturbance and what do we mean by a
medium well we could come up with some
fairly simple examples let's say that i
have a let's say i have a little puddle
here so that's my little puddle
and let's say i were to drop a stone in
that puddle so this is my stone it gets
dropped in the puddle and we've all seen
what happens right when it goes into the
water that pushes that water down pushes
the water around it out then that water
comes back up and then you have this
traveling disturbance
you have this traveling disturbance
these
these kind of rings start to radiate
outward from
from where
from where i actually
from where i actually dropped
dropped the pebble and you can actually
see them you can actually see them move
outwards you can see the crests of those
waves move outwards so we're talking
about a disturbance well this is that
disturbance we the the pond was
completely flat but then we agitated we
pushed it down it pushed the water
outwards and then that pushed the water
next to it up and down up and down and
it traveled outwards from the point of
that initial disturbance so we have this
disturbance
traveling through the medium what's the
medium here
well the medium here is the water
and the disturbance the initial
disturbance was the rock disturbing that
water but then that water disturbed the
water around it which disturbed the
water around it so that disturbance kept
traveling through the medium and we can
give other examples of this
if i take a
let's say if i were to take a really
long string and hold it right there and
that's my hand
so when the sting the string is let's
say it's just attached to something
so let's say it's a really long string
and right now there's there's some slack
in it it's attached to a wall
and let's say that i were to start
moving my hand up and down so i move my
hand up and down what's going to happen
well if i just let's just think about if
i just did it once if i just did it once
what i'm going to have is this lump of
string
move
from the left to the right so that's
what it's going to look like
at first then a few seconds later it's
going to look like it's going to look
like this
it's going to look something like this
and you're going to have this
disturbance which is this this this wave
this lump that i just generated it is
going to move it is going to move
to the right what's the medium the
medium in this case is the string
it is the string and what what what just
happened there well when i jerk it when
i jerk the string up i'm disturbing
those string molecules right next to my
hand and they're pulling on the string
molecules next to them pulling on the
string molecules next to them and so you
then you have this traveling lump so
once again these are both examples of
waves disturbances traveling through
through a medium
now i can give other
through a
medium i could give other examples sound
waves what causes sound waves well you
have a bunch of you have a bunch of air
particles
all bouncing around at actually
surprisingly fast
surprisingly fast speeds but if you
disturb them if you cause something to
say compress a bunch of air particles
right here so these air particles get
ultra compressed some type of clap
happens
so these get ultra compressed well then
they're going to bounce on the ones next
to them and so once again you have this
disturbance traveling through the medium
in this case the medium is the air the
medium is the air
so now that we've seen some classical
notions of ways
let's think about something a little bit
more mysterious and that is the notion
of light
we do believe light has well light
definitely has wave-like properties
light can interfere with each other we
could do a whole other videos on on
light if i were to take
if i were to take
some
if i were to take a barrier like that
with two small slits in it
with two small slits in it and if i were
to shine some light
if i were to shine some light one way to
think about is these slits are the only
place where the disturbation the the the
disturbance gets through and then it
would cause the light to propagate from
each of them like that and maybe i'm
just drawing the crests of the waves but
also come out from here
and so you can see where the two crests
where the two crests meet they're going
to constructively
constructively enhance each other
they're going to constructively
interfere and if you were to put some
type of detector if you were to put some
type of a detector right over here you
would see you would see the bright
points of the light and you would see
the dark points of the light so light
definitely behaves like a wave i'm just
showing even just one example of light
being behaving like a wave
but if it is a wave well that means it
needs to be or if we use our classical
logic you would say well that means it's
a disturbance traveling through a medium
but what is that medium you know we have
light coming from our sun
we call it sunlight we have we have
light coming i keep wanting to make it a
actually our sun is white we tend to
draw it as a yellowish color but that's
just because of its what happens as it
goes through the atmosphere so
you have the sun
you have the earth this is not drawn to
scale and somehow that light is able to
reach us over 93 million miles
over 93 million miles what's it what's
it going through is it a disturbance
traveling through a medium well for a
long time people said well it must be it
has these wave like properties
it's it's it seems to be traveling with
it with a velocity the speed of light so
there must be a medium that is traveling
through and people theorize what this
medium is they called it the
luminiferous ether let me write that
down because it's a fun word
it's a good name for band luminiferous
lumen
lume
nin i'm not spelling it luminiferous
ether
and it was this idea that maybe in even
in the vacuum of space even in the
vacuum of space
you have this
this substance this luminous
luminesce ether that the light is
traveling through that it's somehow a
disturb it's a disturbance in
that luminiferous
luminiferous ether now what we're going
to do in future videos is we're going to
test that we're going to see if that's
actually the case because what's
interesting about if there is a
luminiferous ether well we're not going
to be stationary relative to that
luminiferous ether in fact we're
orbiting we're orbiting around the sun
the sun is orbiting around the center of
the galaxy there's no way that we're
going to be we're going to be stationary
relative to that luminiferous ether so
if we're not stationary relative to that
luminiferous ether we should be able to
detect how light behaves if it's going
kind of in the direction of ether or if
it's going against the direction of the
relative movement of the ether relative
to us so anyway i'll leave you there
this mystery of science you know waves
disturbance through a medium we saw that
with the water with the air with the
string but what about light is there a
luminiferous ether put a question mark
there